I think it's unwise to make a confident
prophecy in what technology will or
won't eventually be able to do I think
that cuts both ways that is it's people
have looked foolish by saying that
something will never happen but they've
also looked foolish by saying that
something is inevitable so there are
things that we can accomplish
technologically that we as a society
have chosen not to such as passenger
supersonic air transport I think if you
were to say to someone in 1957 the speed
of commercial jets now is going to be
the same as the speed of commercial jets
in that 2016 50 60 years from now
they're say you're nuts technology goes
up up up up up but sometimes it doesn't
because people don't like sonic booms
and jet fuel got too expensive
likewise if you would have said in 1972
no one is gonna set foot on the moon for
another 44 years and Counting again they
would say oh no technology always lifts
us higher and higher but sometimes it
doesn't think Cold War ended people lost
interest there all kinds of social and
economic factors that in combination
make the future of technology inherently
unpredictable and I think in engineering
human intelligence to say nothing of
human genius no one knows but I would I
put my money with no for one thing there
are moral and legal taboos people think
that introducing traits into offspring
is a form of eugenics and is on a
slippery slide to Nazism I happen to
think that that is a bogus ethical
argument but it is by far the majority
ethical argument and in many countries
genetic enhancement is or will be
illegal and it's gonna take a huge force
to overcome that just as cloning is
illegal in virtually every country and
when Dolly the sheep was cloned in 1997
they were confident predictions that
there's nothing you could do to stop
human cloning it was just around the
corner and here we are almost 20 years
later and it has not happened also the
task of
Engineering high intelligence is turning
out to be a lot harder than one might
have thought in the late 90s it was
thought well sooner or later you will
find some high IQ genes they'll give you
you know three or four points you'd put
in a handful of them and you get a much
smarter baby there was going to be the
gene for musical talent and the gene for
athletic coordination well you have
every reason to believe that those
traits are substantially heritable we've
known that for decades just because of
twin and adoption studies in the other
hand we also know that the genes
responsible are going to each one of
them is going to have an eensy-weensy
effect and there are dozens hundreds
maybe thousands of them so making your
child smart is not a question of putting
in one high IQ gene it may be a question
of putting in a hundred genes or a
thousand genes
every time you monkey with the genome
you are taking a chance that something
will go wrong also those genes the ones
that we have identified and we've made
enormous progress in just a few years
ago there was not a single gene you
could point to that had a positive
effect on intelligence now we can point
to a few of them they have you know incy
wincy affects 1/3 of an IQ point but on
the other hand we identify them by their
correlations with intelligence we have
no idea what they do I mean if you find
that any of those genes is actually
expressed in the brain then you've had a
really good day as a scientist but to
know what the totality of their effects
are positive and negative is something
that we're not going to know for a long
time if ever when you're talking about
hundreds or thousands of genes how do we
know that one of those genes that give
raises your IQ by a third of a point
doesn't also increase your chance of
epilepsy or schizophrenia or brain
cancer now you're going to go to a
review board and ask for permission to
monkey with a human embryo and they're
gonna say what is the so we know what
the benefits are of implanting this gene
what are the costs and the answer is we
don't know you think that they're going
to have that's going to meet approval or
do you think for that matter that
parents are going to be willing to take
such chances with the biological
integrity of their children that in
changed for an increase of an IQ point
or two they're going to take some
unknown risk of making the child
schizophrenic or bipolar or some other
disease who that we may not know of
whose probabilities we don't know not so
clear that they will now there is the
argument parents will do anything to
enhance their the flourishing of their
children look at the way parents buy
test prep courses and struggle to get
them into the IV's and so on I think
that's true probably of the social
circle of the people who make those
predictions where IQ has outsize
importance but even then there are
people do strongly distinguish
biological interventions from
environmental ones at least
psychologically that's why we still
don't have any sport where athletes can
dope all they want you might say well
what what difference does it make
whether you increase your red blood cell
count by training at a high altitude or
by taking a drug
well biologically there may not be that
much of a difference psychologically
there's all the difference in the world
we just don't think that it is the same
thing when you can when you can cheat
and achieve an advantage through sheer
biological interventions I'm not gonna I
wouldn't say that for sure that's going
to stand in the way of parents enhancing
their children genetically but on the
other hand I think it's it's unwise to
say that it will have no effect that
that we know that those psychological
barriers will be overcome